Roselyn come on in now that I know you a
little bit I'm still a little bit afraid
of you but that's okay you see the
orange chair that's your okay
frontrunner chair Rosman thank you so
much for being here today I really
appreciate it it's very nice to be here
you know it's been a while since you've
wrapped gone girl now do you feel like
amy has still stuck with you all of
these months later he is funny when we
open the film in New York I felt it was
right after that that she really
intruder left me because although I said
oh you know I went to Hawaii after we
finished shooting and you know I think
she left me behind then I think it was
quite true because I then had to embark
on this weird press tour where I had to
keep all the secrets of the movie I
wasn't allowed to fully speak about it
or reveal anything or or even imply that
I might not be the dead girl and so in a
way I was just continuing to play Amy I
was still peddling duplicity and lies
and and sort of duping people yeah just
as Amy does so it wasn't until finally I
could really talk about it after the end
of September and then I felt this kind
of weight lifts off my shoulders I'm
sure you did it's such a fantastic
performance it's earned you your first
Oscar nomination so congratulations on
that but my understanding is that one of
your very first great theater roles as a
younger woman almost didn't happen at
all is that true Theater was all I knew
growing up and in England we have
something called the National Youth
Theatre which is a kind of place that
young people between 16 and 21 can meet
and and do their passion exercise their
passion which is theatre drama and you
audition in you're part of a course and
it's like a sort of big summer camp
really and after you've done that the
course for the first year which is a lot
of improv and a lot of kind of trust
games and you then eligible to become
part of the season and and I didn't get
in I didn't get in to be any part of the
company so I started temping doing
office work in a in an agency in
Victoria in London and
suddenly one day my mom called and said
the National Youth Theater are getting
trying to get hold of you and I rang up
and they said well the girl we cast as
Juliet has just been cast in a
television show and our director would
like you to be Juliet and suddenly there
I was transported into this world and
I've since then I've never minded being
picked second not being first choice
being the substitute you know less
pressure sometimes to be number two
so speaking of great roles to play you
got to play Amy Elliott Dunne Gillian
Flynn's fantastic lead character in gone
girl so let's take a look at one of your
great scenes with Neil Patrick Harris
from this movie we can watch it together
with these remotes so we should tell
people that he Neil Patrick Harris
character is a bit obsessed with
butterfly collector who's finally caught
me and isn't it yes yes touches let's
see how it goes Amy it's time to move on
what can I do to help I need some time
to think that's the last thing you need
desi one two years you have kept me
dangling okay I'm stopping here because
this is the perfect chance to talk about
the look that Amy's rocking at this
point in the movie but what are we
looking at here are we looking at
padding are we looking at something that
they put in your face prosthetic wise or
did you gain the weight I had to gain
and lose 12 pounds that's what Gillian
writes about in her book that's what Amy
does she kind of hides inside her body
as she goes on the run it's partly to
become less recognizable as her image is
disseminated as she becomes missing the
missing persons image when she needs to
hide and partly as a kind of retaliation
against the cool girl image that she's
peddled for so long so yes I did have a
diet of milkshakes and burgers but then
as you know many women will relate to
the the weight sort of went on my hips
and my butt which is less useful for the
camera you know I gained the twelve
pounds but it wasn't necessary where
they wanted it we then did have to do a
bit of padding so it's it's a it's a
genuine mixture but the authenticity is
there underneath all right well let's
keep watching and see how it goes
finally last night you came to me and
you chose me follow that instinct don't
trust the instinct that left you beaten
and homeless sleeping in your car
fearing for your life this is a moment
in the movie where
you're kind of learning that someone
else can play your game your husband
Nick has gone on TV on this big
interview and kind of spoken to you
through the interview and it's kind of
setting you off a little bit well they
said it's a brilliant moment because
obviously Amy Unleashed this whole plan
to accuse her husband of murder he then
goes on one of the biggest television
shows and performs brilliantly and says
everything she wants him to say and the
thing about Amy because of her being
this sociopathic creature she doesn't
care if the whole thing as a Sherrod
it's the fact that he said it and that
is good enough for her it's this is this
take on relationships that it doesn't
matter if you're acting as long as it's
a game I want you to play and that was
also sort of chilling about her all
right well let's see how it continues
I'm not gonna force myself on you I love
your face here because I feel like the
wheels are turning
it's very sparse writing by Gillian in
this scene it's it's a very it's a very
interesting edit of the whole idea of
this very stressed at relationship this
is where she sheets he realizes that the
cool girl that desi wanted is not the
cool girl that Nick wanted so this is
her realizing she's got to get back to
the high school sweetheart that desi had
and we're gonna see her start to perform
that creature yeah you're gonna turn it
on right about now push play I
understand what you're saying busy
just and so mistreated for so long
Elisa's decided that behave was just a
word that was gonna turn desi on and of
course it doesn't quite work because she
hasn't yet got the face and the body
back voice and it's just this idea I was
like well you see this line and you
think how am I gonna get this to work
I've forgotten how to behave and then
you realize that it's not genuine and of
course that's always the key to a me you
think how my god is oh it's not entirely
genuine yeah
alright here's some more of the scene
I'll move in here tomorrow and we'll
work it out together now here I don't
even know you have him also I know that
him moving in is gonna make me trapped
because he is the butterfly collector
there's no man I know who's like dizzy
hmm who takes someone into this house
and and surrounds him with security
cameras and when when she first moves in
he says you know you'll be utterly safe
you know no one gets in or out well this
is a great look for you here I just want
you to be you again
what are we going to do with this dark
rat's tail that's surrounding your face
and I love the music to there it's just
so foreboding you know what they worked
over that paid David and Atticus and
Trent Reznor took the idea of spa music
that music you hear when you go into a
spar and it's just sort of benign
relaxing background music and they've
taken that and then really brought out
all the sinister undertones I'm so safe
I'm so safe oh I'm really not safe at
all wow I love this moment in the movie
I think it's a turning point crazy stuff
happens in the next few minutes but this
sets it all up so it's great to see you
and I really appreciate your time thank
you now if you have not seen gone girl
be sure to check it out and thanks so
much for watching
Fandango frontrunner to say thank you
for being with us we have made you your
very own Amy Elliott Dunne
Fandango gift card so please take this
and enjoy some movies on us with your
friends and family isn't that great so
now we're gonna take our picture follow
me over yeah stand with me here I'll do
it I'll do a three count one two three
love it thank you so much
you